forschungsteams weltweit sind dabei
unsere ernährung komplett umzustellen
upzudaten heißt also konkret
ersatzstoffe für zucker und fett lange
haltbarkeit ohne chemie und fleisch aus
dem labor was sind also die neuesten
trends aus den laboren der
lebensmitteltechnologie und sind sie
wirklich gesünder und nachhaltiger das
alles und noch viel mehr jetzt bei
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen und am ende des videos habe
ich noch ein gutes für euch eine hammadi
ein kostenloses exemplar der zeitschrift
technology review sehr kohle in
zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion ist
dieses video entstanden eine große
umfrage von anfang des jahres zeigt dass
wir deutschen durchaus bereit sind uns
gesünder zu ernähren mehr als die hälfte
der befragten sprach sich für
verbindliche höchstwerte von salz zucker
und fett aus kann hier die
lebensmitteltechnologie helfen wir haben
für euch die vier spannendsten aspekte
zusammengestellt süße ohne zucker
mittlerweile ist zucker sogar noch
unbeliebter als fett kein wunder dass
die liste der ersatzstoffe lang estland
malta isomalt money gebiet sind oft zwar
genau so süß wie zucker haben aber viele
kalorien süßstoffe wie aspartam haben
zwar keine kalorien machen aber auf
dauer trotzdem dick teilweise wirken sie
auch abführen ein nachteil von stevia
ist der bittere nachgeschmack
forschungsteams weltweit haben also eine
große aufgabe finde eine substanz die so
süß wie zucker aber keine der gerade
genannten nachteile mit sich bringt ein
forschungsteam des massachusetts
institute of technology mit hat sich
deswegen zur aufgabe gemacht dem stevia
süßstoffe den bitteren beigeschmack zu
nehmen dazu haben sie entsprechende
pflanzen gene in bakterien eingebaut so
dass diese die leckeren stevia
bestandteile produzieren das bittere
beiprodukt steviosid dagegen nicht die
substanz gilt nach ersten prüfungen als
gesundheitlich unbedenklich
die deutsche brain ag setzt auf die
suche in pflanzen naturstoff datenbank
mann hat bereits 60 kandidaten
identifiziert die mindestens achtung das
50 fache der zucker süßkraft aufweisen
und jetzt wird geprüft welche stoffe für
welche lebensmittel am besten geeignet
sind fest steht jedenfalls
zucker in gerichten machen diese nicht
nur süß sondern kaschieren auch
bitterstoffe und so lautet die
grundlegende frage wie entsteht
eigentlich der geschmacks eindruck
gezuckerte erdbeeren schmecken intensiv
nach früchten salz dagegen macht den
gewünschten erdbeergeschmack kaputt
diese mechanismen nämlich dass sich die
geschmacksstoffe gegenseitig
beeinflussen könnte man gezielt
ausnutzen der zuckeranteil könnte durch
den einsatz von vanille noten oder
auszügen der tonkabohne reduziert werden
wenn diese intensivieren das empfinden
von süße dazu der forscher christian
zacherl kennt man solche zusammenhänge
lässt sich der zuckergehalt und bis zu
20 prozent und der salzgehalt sogar um
20 bis 30 prozent senken aber auch die
verteilung des zuckers spielt eine
wichtige rolle wenn er auf der produkt
oberfläche aufgetragen ist schmeckt es
gleich süßer als wenn der zucker
gleichmäßig eingearbeitet ist doch die
reduktion von zucker hat auch seine
nachteile beispielsweise eine kürzere
haltbarkeit denn zucker entzieht
bakterien das wasser und hemmt so ihr
wachstum der lebensmittelkonzern nestlé
dagegen versucht den zucker neu zu
erfinden und zwar ohne kalorien
er hat poröse zucker partikel entwickelt
die sich genau wie zuckerwatte schnell
auf der zunge auflösen so ließe sich der
zuckergehalt von süßwaren um bis zu 40
prozent reduzieren und das ohne dass der
geschmack darunter leide
noch dieses jahr sollen die ersten
produkte auf den markt kommen geschmack
ohne fett lange zeit wurden fette
regelrecht verteufelt heute dagegen
gehen viele expertinnen und experten
davon aus dass zucker weitaus
schädlicher ist dennoch zu viel fett und
vor allem zu viel gesättigte fettsäuren
gelten noch immer als ungesund
transfette die bei der verarbeitung von
sojaöl entstehen sind in den usa seit
2015 sogar verboten
fettreduzierte produkte sollen das übel
mindern sie werden aber von vielen auch
als nicht so lecker empfunden kein
wunder denn fett ist geschmacksträger
nummer eins fed liebende substanzen
lösen sich in ihm und ihr geschmack wird
dadurch verstärkt als ausweg wird dann
auf zucker eingesetzt um den fehlenden
geschmack zu kompensieren das
us-unternehmen schoko funes hat eine
modifizierte fed struktur
an den start gebracht die denselben
geschmack liefert aber eben ohne die
lästigen kalorien die idee ist schon
einige jahrzehnte alt und ziemlich
clever drei fette und ein molekül
glyzerin bilden zusammen die struktur
von fetten durch den einbau eines
abstandhalter moleküls wird das
modifizierte fettmoleküle aber nicht
abgebaut und verstaut sondern direkt
wieder ausgeschrieben
dieser fällt ersatz wird apple genannt
und ist noch nicht in unabhängigen
studien untersucht worden
auch lupinen proteine könnten demnächst
als fett ersatz dienen zwar auch mit
kalorien ausgestattet aber bei weitem
nicht so viele wie bei fed setzt die
protein suspension ist dickflüssig und
ähnelt partikel in bratwurst sie könnte
also den geschmack von fettarme wurst
deutlich verbessert fleisch ohne tiere
ja er ist es alles zunächst einmal sind
da ja die ethischen aspekte aber auch
für die umwelt bedeutet die
massentierhaltung eine riesige
katastrophe denn um beispielsweise ein
mastschwein heran zu ziehen braucht es
fast eine million liter trinkwasser und
zwar ganz allein um sein futter
anzubauen gefüttert wird es
hauptsächlich mit soja für dessen anbau
beispielsweise regenwälder in brasilien
weichen müssen
das grundwasser wird durch die
massentierhaltung verschmutzt und zwar
mit nitrat durch die gülle werden die
böden über den große mengen an
stickstoff lagern sich im boden ab und
sorgen dafür dass verschiedene tier und
pflanzenarten sterben und zuletzt wird
auch der klimawandel durch die
massentierhaltung gefördert zitat wir
wollen dass für die fleischindustrie
sein was das auto für die pferdekutsche
war sagt jura valette der chef des
kalifornischen start up unternehmens
memphis meets seine produkte kommen nach
eigenen angaben ohne antibiotika
schlachtungen und hormone aus zudem
sollen dabei rund 90 prozent weniger
treibhausgase entstehen
memphis meets lässt fleisch im
bioreaktor wachsen hier vereinen sich
muskelzellen zu fleischtöpfen investoren
sind der virgin gründer richard branson
und microsoft gründer bill gates die
herstellungskosten dieser produkte die
sind mit immer noch 4000 dollar pro
pfund also pro halbes kilo pro kilo sind
8000 dollar
doch die verantwortlichen sind
optimistisch den preis in den nächsten
drei jahren so zu senken dass die
produkte es auf den markt
klar auch dann werden es immer noch
luxusprodukte sein und die ersten
abnehmer werden wohl edelrestaurants
seien aber spätestens in fünf jahren
soll es dann auf dem massenmarkt niveau
angekommen seien dazu der
geschäftsführer von mosambik peter vest
rate wir haben herausgefunden dass
sowohl die produktionsbedingungen als
auch die nährstoff kosten verbessern
können das macht uns zuversichtlich
langfristig so günstig wie normales
fleisch zu werden wahrscheinlich sogar
noch günstiger sein unternehmen nimmt
als nährmedium nicht mehr das ethisch
problematische fetale kälber serum
sondern das blut ungeborener kälber auch
antibiotika wollen die hersteller nach
eigenen angaben nicht mehr einsetzen
doch es gibt weitere herausforderungen
denn bisher sind nur sehr dünne
zellschichten bis zu einem millimeter
möglich also alles andere als ein die
gestik denn dann lassen sich die cellent
also wenn sie dicker werden nicht mehr
ausreichend mit nährstoffen versorgen
dennoch gehen mikrobiologen davon aus
dass dieses fleisch durchaus gesünder
sein könnte und wohl auch nachhaltiger
als die konventionellen
fleischproduktion das sagt zumindest
eine studie aus dem jahr 2011 die einer
tonne labor fleisch einen günstigeren
umwelt fußabdruck bescheinigt als
derselben menge tier fleisch beim
energieverbrauch ist das ganze wohl noch
nicht mehr also nicht mehr so ganz klar
hier ist der aufwand für das kultur
fleisch wohl größer als beim
herkömmlichen freistaats zumindest legt
eine studie aus dem jahr 2015
dann kommt es letztendlich wohl noch auf
den geschmack an
und das müssen dann wird die verbraucher
entscheiden ob das wirklich als
fleischersatz die haltbar ohne chemie
bislang sorgen chemische substanzen in
unseren nahrungsmitteln dafür dass sich
gefährliche pilze und bakterien in ihnen
vermehren doch sie sollen langfristig
durch gesundheitlich unbedenkliche
konservierungsmittel ersetzt werden denn
schon jetzt werfen wir deutschen pro
jahr 82 kilogramm lebensmittel weg eine
ziemlich schlimme zahl für die wir uns
eigentlich schämen sollten das deutsche
institut für lebensmitteltechnik schlägt
das sogenannte pool hughes verfahren vor
bei dem die membran der keime mit
pulsierenden elektrischen feldern durch
löcher wird damit könnten fruchtsäfte
haltbar gemacht werden bis zu
wochenlang zudem würden vitamine und
geschmack geschont wenn das verfahren
beim frittieren von pommes oder chips
eingesetzt wird gibt es sogar einen
tollen nebeneffekt die produkte nehmen
bis zu 30 weniger fett auf aber auch
pflanzenextrakte können nahrungsmittel
haltbar machen beispielsweise hopfen
bestandteile kennt man vom bier
das steigert die haltbarkeit von fleisch
marinaden zum beispiel um 50 prozent so
die forschungsergebnisse rosmarin
extrakt wird übrigens bei tiefkühlpizzen
schon als natürliches und schönes
konservierungsmittel eingesetzt das
frauenhofer iv institut baut gerade eine
datenbank auf um zu analysieren wo genau
die geschmacksschwelle für solche
naturstoffe liegt also vielen dank an
technology review in zusammenarbeit mit
der redaktion dieser ziemlich coolen
zeitschrift ist dieses video entstanden
und exklusiv wirklich zum zuschauer habe
ich jetzt ein geschenk ihr bekommt
nämlich eine ausgabe gratis wenn ihr auf
diesen link klickt dass man sich
wirklich und da drunter geht es weiter
mit dafür auch draufklicken erschreckend
wir essen unmengen micro plastik bis
dann bleibt dran